bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono fatti j
oggi sono corra che sarebbe lui prima
mentre assistiamo su quattro boss sono
in questa posizione molto sexy
sto registrando col portatile è
praticamente non posso giocare a
battlefield quindi lo sa fare un gioco
un po così gli ho detto ma perché la
facciamo qualche airbus che un gioco con
una grafica e sonoro va bene comunque la
posizione mi sembrava sexy quindi non vi
lamentate perchè tanto lo so che tutti
siano a vedermi così
[Musica]
comunque ragazzi siamo sue cure boss che
ha già mi stai sul cu lo zio quindi
tipino la matita in realtà volevo
semplicemente fargli un autografo
va bene uguale se tu cosa fai eppure
circola musica minola beh ragazzi è il
mio ha vinto ha vinto tutto ciò che
questo tizio è quello che portava fuori
la spazzatura legava a me succede ancora
o no no no no non lo dici a tua mamma
mentre si chiama l'ebraico munch e
ragazzi si sono un board e ce ne sono 24
ricortola formiano io chiedevo col
compiuto sono filosofia è quello che è
un letto ma gli ho dato va bene
ancora grazie perfetto a posto è sporco
allora va bene ragazzi che mi facendo
non seriamente molto istruttivo
l'orologio posso prenderlo a me lo passò
lui
minchia che è il jet ma sei serio no
vabbè dai no va bene se stessa per
questa la mia preferita in assoluto
mi chiamo nightshot da un chilometro
anche il calcio nel maronia vabbè ma
poverino gli ha spaccato la faccia non è
thomas forme non si è fatto male
non so se posto fantastico gioco di
squadra gioca è lo stesso che facciamo
io era la vera riporta lo sportello si è
certo ascoltati o forse non si stacca se
spari meno figure di merda jaguar di
perfetto della serie non possiamo
portare lo scaffale dal boss portiamo al
boss dallo scappano
jenny ha vinto tutto ha vinto
fottutamente ogni cosa non ho parole la
chiamiamo netturbino bravo zio reggio
emilia che camera già che ci sei novero
l'appendiabiti e cosa no va bene ma
stanno ballando
lo sbaglio
sono molto carini insieme come non detto
eh vabbè succede storia d'amore
finiscono in modo tragico però io darei
un bel 9 al ballo molto bravo il
telefono prima chiamato tua madre
puntate che cosa sta succedendo mio di
eva venter è un telefono non è una trave
di ferro la madonna sembra un nuovo re
quando abbiamo provato tutte qui sotto
l'ombrello e la cosa che madonna che
prendano masticasse mammella colon è un
ombrello era stata di excalibur era lo
aspetta bebè sticazzi non sono mai più
un ombrello in tutta la mia vita
violenza jesus alto abbiamo di cos'è
questo perché ci è toccato al computer
s.messa prendono a cazzotti a caso va
bene ok che fa assieme sarà adesso
adesso s'è messo a fare yoga no vabbè
perché al posto della musica a volte si
preferisce lo yoga ma che cos'è una
penna e vabbè mica diretto nei maroni
quanto me lo fai a kg la salsiccia 0
tema per ogni porta ragazzi oggi abbiamo
incredibilmente imparato che le penne e
gli ombrelli sono letali
basta una penna per ammazzare un uomo e
per comprare la salsiccia di certo l
unico con la valigia pisa sì sì ancora
una ancora una non so se ho sentito
bravo ancora secondo me non si è fatto
malissimo
chiuderei anche la valigia è poi lo
spedisce in corea hai voglia
bravo ecco perché adesso il francobollo
e siamo a posto che fanno i samsung
galaxy con le persone vive anzi morte
molto morte non posso fare le sue la
scopa e ramazza la pesca è la madonna
valentina queste avevamo affinché
cascone sta godendo di 50 sfumature di
rosso per terra
secondo me ha goduto il cassetto ci
mancava il caso ovviamente mi ha detto
mi ha detto stop è presente tua mamma
con la brutta ecco e poi dire sto per i
cazzi st dicembre gatto dove d sta
cassetto zio di marconato 8 blog poesia
la polizia nelle orecchie quelli altro
che canzoni in musica che tra la poesia
prova ancora grazie per i mali che
chiude anche gli occhi perché sta
accadendo ma la cosa e volti b
lentamente godibile e morto forse mi è
piaciuto ragazzi lodo a questa primo
posto in assoluto la 6 piano anche la
mia sedia ma se prendono a cazzola psi
ogni volta che ti dico qualcosa cosa gli
ho messo loca questa pensavo pensavo
facesse di più e mai l'orchestra andato
mio dio ragazzi ed è ultimo secondo me
sono arrivato prima di valentino
quel position
ti ho fatto un po di vita vabbè si
arrangiano è stato bello lo stesso posso
tornare a sedermi con lo sgabello non ci
aveva più una sedia prendendosi
bellissimo va beh questo non c'è gioco
migliore di questo perché non mi
interessa la tastiera della tastiera mi
piace ma guarda workshop 9 questa mia
vita ho fatto abbastanza schifo lo vede
che non posso finire il mio lavoro
adesso che c'è lei la tastiera come
faccio c'è anche lei cazzo fuori aiuto
emilia una mano saiwa lei la possiamo
tra la traccia ma cosa che ad azzate
infatti va bene ci metti anche dello
zucchero per favore un po di caffè da
che ci siamo bravo è stato gara pacman
il cazzo fattoria il reality ma è un
righello e un coltello da lancio ma
fatemi capire pinzatrice ai ragazzi è
esattamente così casa attaccano i fogli
proprio così perché il monitor mi sta
guardando malissimo d'accordo le forbici
o mio dio
la gioia vuole come le scruta proprio
deve sentire il sapore della morte
eccolo
niente doccia io sono a posto così è
rimasta la forma sul muro che cacciari
manca questa la prima cosa d'acqua ma
non è che cartone di maroni
bravo vai a prendere tutte le il culo
the game posizione vai così bravo bravo
e veloce notes è girato e va beh secondo
me non c'è più 7 per un bel po e morto
oh mio dio
ecco quando dicono non bisogna bere non
bevete proprio cioè proprio non fatelo
il vaso c'è ancora viva mi sa che botta
mi stavo divertendo maledizione era
bello il telefono l'ho fatto la lampada
alla lampada mi mancano ancora tre facce
felici questa cosa già finito breve ma
intenso ragazzi è stato è stato alquanto
tra massimo ma ancora due vai o no no no
no no ma neanche in saw l'enigmista c'è
ai vini ti ordino paio di scarpe nuove
non fanno sapere perché siamo già a
posto ragazzi ci stiamo avvicinando alla
fine incredibile manca al cestino sempre
con licenziato sei serio
niente fa ci fai arrestare tua nonna tre
volte per il piatto di lasagne
eccessivamente grande grazie la mia mano
c'è posso switch armi sulla ma è va beh
gli ho rotto
mi spiace di storia in alto per per fare
rock i sei cielo di lavorazione dal muro
che cosa c'è di armi che non avevo visto
ancora ragazzi
il finale è stato fatto non avevo visto
lo fa quella zona che scappa dalle
società scappi zia blemi che in fiamme
guarda che ti stanno operando dalla
dalla tragedia del lavoro tutto
incidendo il capo sono stabili ecco lei
lei e lei è contenta non è anche se n'è
andata non c'è prima non c'è più
meritocrazia in questo caso di mondo
volano sedie libro quando l'hai droppato
è anche il modo violento beh io un
facile e tranquillo proprio i ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto guai orbo
stessa con quanto stanno fare un
gameplay è ridotto così proprio figlio
però lui è stato mi ha aiutato
abbastanza quindi non ha problemi a
parte il fatto che è stata una figata a
parte è piaciuto zio porco boia zio è
stato una figata grande ma lo sapeva io
scelgo solo giorni che sono figli altro
che batte figlio fratello di giocare con
me cosa minchia dici che porta questo
nome di fare un cazzo
nel web
nel web ne vorrei